Okay.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Tessal Röftas.
Ich bin die zuständige Eisbind für Sie.
Bevor wir zu Ihren Bescheiden kommen,
lassen Sie mich ein bisschen, ein paar persönliche Daten notieren.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Ingelkorthaus.
Okay, könnten Sie ja vor und nachnahme langsam und kurz stabilisieren.
Ja, der Vorname INGE.
I-V-I-T-O-T-E-V-E-N-G-I-G-E.
Ja, Ingel, okay.
Und der Familienname ist Korthaus.
K-O-R-T-E-N-G-E-N-G-E-N-G-E-N-G-E.
Und dann H-A-U-S Haus am Ende.
Ha, u, haus, normal, wie haus.
Korthaus, ja.
Ja, sehr wichtig deswegen.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin gerade 40 Jahre.
Sehr gut.
Waren die genauso wie wir geworden?
Am 7.8.82.
2 und 8.
Ja, ha, korthaus, ja.
Wie groß und wie schliessen Sie?
Ja, ich bin 1,74 und ich wiech so ziemlich genau 75 kg.
75 kg, okay.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Marklerin.
Marklerin, okay.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin geschieden und hab aber meine Kinder bei mir.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
3.
Frau, korthaus, was können Sie tun?
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich beide haben Sie im Moment.
Ja, ich glaube, das Schlimmste ist jetzt gerade schon durch,
aber ich habe so unglaublich heftige Kopfschmerzen.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
ich kann überhaupt nicht mehr gerade ausgucken.
Ich habe so ganz bohrende, heftige Schmerzen.
Ich konnte überhaupt kein Licht vertragen.
Jedes Geräusch in der Umgebung ist die Hölle für mich.
Jetzt ist mir so unglaublich schlecht.
Ich musste gerade auch noch mal auf die Toilette gehen,
weil ich das Gefühl hatte, ich muss mich übergeben.
Aber dann kam eigentlich gar nichts.
Ich habe mich schon 2-3 Mal übergeben.
Eigentlich habe ich gar nichts mehr im Magen,
aber ich fühle mich wirklich ganz schlecht.
Und diese Kopfschmerzen,
ganz langsam werden sie ein bisschen besser.
Aber ich hatte das Gefühl, ich kann das nicht mehr aushalten.
Okay, ich habe verstanden.
Okay.
Wann sind Ihre Schmerzen aufgetreten?
Ja, das fing heute Vormittag an.
Vormittag?
Ja.
Und zwar habe ich das mit einmal gemerkt,
dass ich nicht rausgucken konnte
oder gar nicht gut gucken konnte.
Dass da alles irgendwie komisch aus.
Ich war geblendet von der Sonne.
Und nach einer Weile fing das an.
Das war eigentlich so wie angeflogen,
dann ganz plötzlich, dass diese Kopfschmerzen da waren.
Ganz plötzlich.
Hat uns Sie pro Jahr ähnliche beschleiden?
Nein, also klar, hat man mal Kopfschmerzen
oder so, aber solche unangenehmen Beschwerden
habe ich noch nicht gehabt.
Okay, paar Corthaus.
Für Sicherheit würde ich gerne einfach
die Überholfen, zum Beispiel
durch Ihre Zauerstoffstätikung.
Okay, danach werden wir weiter machen.
Okay, gut.
Wir gucken.
Wir gucken und jetzt reden wir weiter.
Wir haben schon ein paar Dinge überlegt.
Es gibt keine Probleme.
Wir machen ja weiter.
Ja, Sie haben schon gesagt,
zwei oder drei Mal, erbrochen.
Ja, Sie haben.
Wie war erbrochen?
Ja, das war mein Frühstück.
Und zum Mittagessen habe ich schon gar nichts mehr gegessen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie plötzlich
mehr erbrochen
oder alles normal
erbrochen oder plötzlich erbrochen?
Also ich musste jetzt nicht
von einer Sekunde auf die andere rausrennen.
Aber ich habe das gemerkt,
dass mir schlecht wurde, dass mir der Speichel zusammenliegt.
Das fühlt sich nicht gut an.
Dann bin ich in den Bad.
Dann krampf ich sich der ganze Magen zusammen,
auch als schon gar nichts mehr drin war.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und bitte weigen oder wagen,
wo dich am Starten ist.
Auf der linken Seite sind die.
Und sie bohren sich so von der Sterne durch
auf die andere Seite.
Halbseitig kann man gerade mehr.
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt,
Ihre Schmerzkarreter oder Schmerzkarreter
bohren die Schmerzen, ja?
Ja, das kann man wirklich so sagen, ja.
Das kann man auch sagen oder nur bohren.
Nee, bohren ist beschreibt es schon sehr gut, ja.
Okay.
Und wie stark Ihre Schmerzen
von einer Schmerzkarre,
von 1 bis 10 wobei 1, der leitende
der starken Schmerzen entspricht.
Boah, also, jetzt flaut es langsam
so ein ganz bisschen ab.
Ich weiß schon, ob ich vielleicht gar nicht kommen müssen,
aber die waren wirklich bei 7, 8, ja.
Jetzt sind sie vielleicht bei 6, 7, würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Ich habe sie etwas dagegen,
1 genommen.
Ja, ich habe 2 Aspirin genommen.
2 Aspirin.
Okay.
Und jetzt, sie sind besser.
Die Schmerzen werden langsam besser,
aber ich denke mal, ich habe das auch wieder ausgespuckt,
diese Tabletten,
weil ich mich dann wieder übergeben musste, ne?
Ja, okay, ich habe verstanden.
Und sie haben etwas gemacht,
sie haben etwas gemacht,
sie haben etwas bemerkt.
Sie haben etwas gemacht,
Sie haben etwas bemerkt,
sie haben etwas bemerkt,
sie haben etwas nicht gut gesehen, ja?
Die neuen Schmerzen ist da wirklich etwas olmuş,
die haben sie nicht gut gesehen, ja?
Ja.
Sie haben etwas bemerkt, sie
ich glaube ParisATION
Also das hat alles vor meinen Augen geschmommen und dann ist mir etwas ganz komisches aufgefallen,
dass meine rechte Hand so gekribbelt hat.
Okay, ansonsten gibt es andere Beschwerden, zum Beispiel Krippen, Taupaltskrippen, Indepthände.
Ja, das habe ich ja gerade geschrieben.
Ja, Krippen.
Und ansonsten gibt es?
Ne, sonst ist mir nichts aufgefallen.
Ja, Ihre Gesicht hat sich verändert oder Ihre Minik?
Ich konnte nicht gut gucken.
Also auch wenn ich in den Spiegel geguckt habe, hatte ich das Gefühl, ich kann mich nicht gut sehen.
Okay, okay.
Ich habe falsch gelernt.
Okay.
Und ja, möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen, Ihre Beschwerden?
Nein, ich hoffe jetzt ja nur, dass die Schmerzen wirklich besser werden, aber ich fühle mich total erschöpft.
Okay, okay.
Ich weiß es.
Und Frau Kurzhaus, leiden Sie an Krönchenerkrankungen?
Ich meine, Bluthochdruck, Lückekrankheit oder Herzkrankheiten?
Nein, so etwas habe ich nicht.
Nein, gar nicht.
Okay.
Sind Sie gegen etwas operiert worden?
Hm, eine Operation habe ich noch nie gehabt noch.
Mhm, sehr gut, okay.
In Ihrer Familie gibt es wichtige Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Migräne, Lückekrankheit oder andere Dinge.
Also meine Mutter, die hatte einen Hirntumor.
Ja, und ist mit, wie ein, ist sie geworden, die ist 73 oder so geworden, dann ist sie halt gestorben, ne?
73, ja.
Am Hirntumor ist sie gestorben.
Sie hatte einen Hirntumor, ja.
Mhm, okay, okay.
73, ja.
Okay.
Und Vater?
Mein Vater?
Der hat eigentlich nichts erlebt, irgendwie, der lebt noch und, und, und, der hat vielleicht so ein paar Gebrechen hier und da, aber so alt ist der ja auch noch nicht.
Und dem geht es eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht, dass der irgendwas hat.
Okay, okay, sehr gut.
Und haben Sie Geschwister und die leiden an irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Nimmer, ich habe keine Geschwister.
Keine Geschwister, okay.
Frau Colthaus, gehen Sie regelmäßig zum Frauenart?
Ja.
Mhm, klar.
Okay, alles in Ordnung?
Da ist eigentlich alles in Ordnung.
Mhm, okay.
Okay.
Und wie ist Ihre Regelbeutung?
Auch alle in Ordnung?
Ja, so mittelregelmäßig, ja.
Mhm, okay, sehr gut.
Und Frau Colthaus, Sie haben bemerkt, dass Sie fieberig sind oder Sie haben Ihre Zöpfe-Kantrofriere gemessen oder haben Sie viel gemacht?
Ach so fieberig? Das Wort hatte ich nicht verstanden, Entschuldigung.
Ja, ich habe mich nicht fieberig gefühlt, ich habe aber auch nicht gemessen, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich habe nicht gemessen.
Mhm.
Okay, und haben Sie Schwierigkeiten ein- oder durchzuschlafen?
Ja, manchmal habe ich so ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten, einzuschlafen, wenn das irgendwie ein stressiger Tag war.
Ah.
Wissen Sie, drei Kinder und Berufstätigkeit, das ist natürlich viel, ne?
Ja, es kann sehr schwierig sein.
Ja, mhm, okay, wir können stressen manchmal, haben Sie Schwierigkeiten.
Mhm, genau.
Ja, appatit.
Ja, also normalerweise ist der eigentlich nicht so schlecht, nur jetzt im Augenblick darf ich nicht mal an Essen denken, ja?
Ja, natürlich.
Sie üben deswegen, ja.
Ja, mir ist üben.
Normalerweise, gut.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme mit einem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, eigentlich läuft das ganz normal.
Okay.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie sind ein bisschen stressig, Sie sind ein bisschen schütteltig und haben Sie auf der Arbeit oder ja, sehr große Schwierigkeiten, die Sie belasten?
Oder zu wenig, oder?
Nein, also, ja, manchmal ist es schon stressig, dann hängt man den ganzen Tag am Telefon und dann gibt es auch mal unangenehme Kunden.
Und, und, prompt, wenn irgendwas schief geht, ist natürlich auch irgendwas bei den Kindern und dann muss man so diese Spar, diesen Spagaten machen, dass man an allen Orten gleichzeitig sein muss.
Aber ja, ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass das, dass das super stressig ist mit der Arbeit.
Die Arbeit alleine wäre es nicht und die Kinder alleine wären es auch nicht.
Aber die Kombination macht es so ein bisschen stressig.
Nein, okay.
Okay.
Und, ähm, nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarfsmedikamente ein?
Ja, eigentlich habe ich nur aspirin, wenn ich mal irgendwie Schmerzen habe, ja.
Okay.
500 mg, ja.
Ja.
Ansonsten gibt es keine Medikamente.
Ne.
Sie, Sie regelmäßig, einen genommen haben oder ja, okay.
Schlauchen Sie fraur, holz Haus?
Nein, mich hat noch nie geraucht.
Nie geraucht, okay, sehr gut.
Und, ähm, schinken Sie Alkohol?
Doch hin und wieder trinke ich ein Glas Wein oder auch mal ein Glas Sekt oder so.
Aber jetzt, ähm, also nicht, nicht jeden Abend oder so, ne?
Nicht jeden Abend, okay.
Okay, ähm, das ist eine routine Frage, nehmen Sie nicht teilweise ein,
haben Sie Kontakt zu, äh, draus Drogen?
Zu Drogen?
Ja, genau.
Nein, nein, nein, also wirklich nicht nein.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und ähm, sind Sie allergisch gegen etwas?
Hm, ich wüsste nicht.
Das jemals, also, was, was ich so auf, auf Insektenstiche reagiere,
ich ziemlich heftig.
Aber ich, also da hat man jetzt noch nicht festgestellt,
dass das eine richtige Allergie ist oder so.
Okay, ähm, haben Sie Unfallkriegigkeiten
oder sind Sie alle Medikamente oder alle, äh,
alle, ums relevanten Platz?
Mhm.
Also Sie meinen so Lebensmittelallergien oder so was?
Ja, Unfallkriegigkeiten haben Sie alle,
also ich kann, ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht alles essen,
ich mag noch nicht alles.
Okay, mhm.
Und, äh, haben Sie in der Zeit, ähm, Gewicht, äh,
Verlohen oder äh, hat Sie, äh, hat Sie, äh,
Nein, leider nicht.
Ja, ja, okay.
Und, äh, ja, ich will gerne ein paar, ja, ähm,
jetzt äh, Ihnen, schmillen Sie?
Ja, vorhin, also mit den Kopfschmerzen,
da war mir so ein bisschen schwindelig
und mit diesen komischen Sehstörungen.
Aber jetzt nicht mehr, ne?
Nicht mehr.
Jetzt ist nur noch so doch diese restlichen Schmerzen
da so auf der Seite sind, ne?
Okay.
Okay, äh, paar Kurthaus, äh, habe ich eigentlich die Fragen,
die ich da traue und Sie fragen, äh, an mich oder
müssen Sie hinzusehen?
Ja, was kann das sein?
Wie kann das sein, wenn Sie dann herkommen,
Sie sind wegen Kopfschmerzen?
Ich mache mir natürlich ein bisschen Sorgen.
Ja, äh, Sie haben recht, Sie haben folgen,
äh, Kopfschmerzen kann das auch sehr wichtig sein,
äh, aber zuerst, äh, haben wir etwas überprüft,
äh, und machen wir weiter.
Leider kann ich zuerst nicht genau zu sagen, äh,
ja, was Sie haben, äh, zuerst,
mit denen ich gerne ein paar Untersuchungen durchführe,
äh, danach können wir äh, etwas sagen, aber das kann
äh, nicht gerne sein, ja, zuerst kann man auch sagen,
aber machen wir, äh, ja, gucken wir, mhm.
Okay, mhm.
Ja, das war es.
Alles gut.
Ja, bitte.
Habt Ihr ein Kollege Fragen?
Sie taucht es rüftlich aus, die Frage nach
Lichtempfindlichkeit.
Ähm, das habe ich eigentlich gesagt, na?
Ja.
Das, dass es eigentlich auch der Auslöser war, na?
Dass ich also irgendwie gemerkt habe, dass ich nicht ins Licht
gucken kann, und äh, jetzt hätte ich wahrscheinlich
eigentlich auch meine Sonnenbrille auf, oder so.
Hm.
Haben Sie Ohr-Geräuschen?
Ohr-Geräusche? Nein, die habe ich wirklich nicht.
Ja.
Wie sich mehr sind abhängig davon, ob Sie sitzen stehen oder liegen?
Hm.
Als ich mich hingelegt habe, hatte ich das Gefühl, Sie sind
ein bisschen besser erträglich, aber weg waren Sie trotzdem nicht.
Also, es hat weiter gebohrt.
Na ja.
Ja, ich bin natürlich gegen Corona geimpft, ist ja klar.
Klar, ja.
Ich habe keine Gipfel.
Ich habe nicht richtig verstanden.
Ernste Bescheidung gehaft, haben Sie?
Nein, nein, habe ich verneilt.
Erst mal?
Ja, erst ist auftreten.
Hm.
Haben Sie Durstgefühl?
Durstgefühl?
Ja, Durstgefühl.
Jetzt habe ich Durst, ja, das stimmt, ja.
Ich werde mal gemessen, haben Sie irgendwie als
Erste mehr gerade gemessen.
Wie viel?
Das ist ja nicht, was dabei rausgekommen ist.
Die hoch der Wett.
Ja, aber ich glaube, der ist, sagen wir mal, der ist nicht extrem
hoch, würde ich sagen.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Stolpen?
Hm.
Ja, okay.
Ja, mal sehen.
Ja, gut, wir sind wirklich gut drauf, ja, sehr schön.
Okay.
Ja, hallo, hao, aber er ist nicht.
Ich würde gerne eine neue Patrientin begriffen.
Ja, Indie Courthouse ist eine
50-jährige Patrientin, die sich wegen
heute Morgen aufgetretene, technische
KVG-Vorgestell hat, Kopfschmerzen, ja.
Und sie hat so dreimal erbrochen
und ihre Schmerzen sein, ja,
plötzlich aufgetreten.
Und ihre Schmerzcharakter sei, wo wenn,
wo man nicht merkt.
Und Schmerz-Internzeit-Liege war, ja,
lag, lieben, am 1.
Lieben oder 8.
Dann hat die Patrientin 2 Mal aspirin,
1000, insgesamt 1000 mg,
eingenommen, danach schmerzt
in Transpilz, Liege, 6 oder 7.
Oder ja, Schmerz hat sich fein in der Einstimmung.
Und die Patienten berichtet das,
sie, Paralyse im rechten Hand haben.
Dauerhaft?
Sie, die, dauert die noch an oder?
Ja, ich hab eigentlich nicht genau gefragt,
aber sie hat gesagt, ich habe die
Spiegel im rechten Hand.
Ah ja, auch eben.
Und sie, Palträg, oder sie kann,
kein Licht, oder ja, sie kann,
kein Licht paltraten.
Mhm.
Ja, mhm.
Und,
am 4. Erkrankung,
ja, der 4. Erkrankung gibt es keine
5. Erkrankung.
Und, an Operationen ist keine Bekannt.
Im Status ist aktuell.
Aber, je weh, mutter,
ist an,
ein Hin-Tumor-Paktor.
Deswegen kann ein
Musikopaktor sein.
Ja, genokologische Anemle
ist unaufreglich und sie,
sie haben ein bisschen
frage Probleme, ja,
ein Schlafen, ja, wir günstig.
Ja, und ansonsten
gibt es keine Medikamente,
die wir regenmäßig angenauen haben.
Ja, ich hab das.
Und das war es.
Ich hab das.
Ja, das war es.
Als klinische Aufgaben,
ja, dort am ehesten mit der Hins,
aber als differential Diagnose
kommt hinzunommen in Betracht.
Ja, ich hab das.
Was könnte differential Diagnostisch noch sein?
Ja, natürlich.
Wenn ein Litz ist,
auch das kann auch sein.
Ja, interprämialer Hämorrhage oder Stachanfalt
oder ja Apokryptik, das kann auch sein.
Ja, genau, ja, ja gut.
Und ja,
und ich würde zuerst,
wie Patienten körperlich unterwuchern,
danach Blut abnehmen.
Ich achte darauf,
zum Beispiel Entzündung,
Parameter, Parametre,
die Enthektionen auszuschreiben.
Ah, ja, okay.
Was machen, oder worauf achten Sie denn
bei der körperlichen Untersuchung besonders?
Ja, natürlich.
Die körperlichen Untersuchungen sind sehr wichtig.
Zum Beispiel
Lesen oder Wiesen
oder Hirnnerven
und Untersuchungen sind sehr wichtig.
Also, wie sonst auch?
Ja, wie sonst auch.
Lichtreflexe von den Puppeln, ne?
Ja, und Gesichtnerven
kann man auch überprüfen.
Ja, das müsste man sicherlich machen
in Seitenvergleichen, ob das immer noch besteht.
Ja, das ist eine Frage.
Ja, kann man auf neurologische Untersuchungen achten.
Ja, man kann.
Und dann
CT, würde ich gerne sagen.
Ja, das ist eine Frage.
Ja, dann macht CT, würde ich gerne sagen.
CT, ja, Schädel.
Ja, okay, genau.
Gut.
Und, ja,
was würden Sie denn der Patientin jetzt,
wenn sich also bestätigt,
dass es also nichts gefährlich ist, kein Tumor,
keine Menigitis?
Ja, genau.
Achten Sie da noch bei der körperlichen Untersuchung,
fällt mir gerade noch so etwas ein.
Ja, genau.
Typische Handgewägung.
Wenn Sie es nicht gemacht hätten, hätte ich jetzt den hier gemacht.
Ja, genau.
Ja, Fachbegel für jetzt.
Also ich weiß es nur auf Deutsch,
Schnappensteifigkeit.
Ja, okay.
Aber das ist eigentlich so diese typische Geschichte,
Natensteifigkeit, ne?
Ja, und was raten Sie der Patientin,
wenn es also tatsächlich die Migräne ist?
Ja, okay.
Migräne ist eine
krönliche Erkrankung.
Man kann
Terriode in
Terriode
diese Beschwerden haben.
Es
kann
manche Auflöse sein,
z.B. Licht, Geräusch, Geräusch,
Schokolade, Käse.
Manche Leverküste, das kann auch auflösen sein.
Man kann diese Auflöse
versichten,
sich auflösen,
auflösen,
versichten,
versichten und beachten.
Und ansonsten gibt es Medikamente.
Ja, okay.
Aber was würden Sie jetzt dieser Patientin akut raten?
Was Sie jetzt macht, wenn sie nach Hause kommt?
Okay.
Ohne Licht.
Ja, genau.
Und Sie haben das von Durst gesagt?
Ja, natürlich.
Ich habe das von Durst gesagt.
Ja, genau.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich habe das von Durst gesagt.
Ja, genau.
Ja, natürlich.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
Ja.
Wir haben sich Drei mal übergeben.
Also alles, was ich vorher drin hatte, war Draußen.
Ja.
Okay, dann würde ich jetzt mal sagen, haben Sie eine Idee, welche Medikamente man speziell
nimmt bei Migräne?
Popiramax oder?
Mittel der ersten Wahl sind NSAR oder aspirin tatsächlich.
Ja, ja.
Die Sänzin hat richtig gemacht.
Ja, ja, ich erinnere mich, ich weiß nicht, ob das überholt ist, das weiß vielleicht
irgendeiner von den Kollegen.
Früher hat man Erguttermin genommen.
Mutterkorn.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das heute noch Mittel der Wahl ist.
Weißt das jemand?
Eine von uns hat Telefon nicht, die ist noch was.
Ja, also wie gesagt, ich bin auch kein Pharmakologe.
Ich bin nur früher tatsächlich selber Migränepatientin gewesen.
Und deswegen weiß ich, dass ich diese gruseligen Pillen nehmen musste.
Und zwar, das war so eine Tablette, die man unter die Zunge,
ah ja, bei Attacca Triptane, kommt wunderbar.
Und das war so eine bittere Tablette, die man unter die Zunge legen musste.
Und wieder Licht, bitter, ja.
Und warten bis die vergeht.
Und das war natürlich eine Ewigkeit, bis sich das aufgelöst hat.
Ah ja, bitter, noch erles ich gerade.
Ja, interessant.
Ja.
Und tatsächlich, also die entscheidenden Faktoren sind Ruhe, Licht aus
und Reizabschirmung, genau.
Und wenn das ganze Ding durch ist, trinken.
Trinken, trinken, trinken.
Man hat unendlichen Durst hinterher.
Das ist Erinnerung.
Und jetzt in diesem Fall habe ich mir überlegt,
bei einer 40-jährigen Patientin,
könnte das ja unter Umständen sein,
dass das so allererste Anzeichen von, von Hormonumstellung oder so was
sind, meistens äußert sich Migreniker so in dieser Phase,
Puertät oder nach halb- wechseljahre oder irgendeinem so was in der Richtung.
Also, das haben sie ja auch schon gesagt,
durch die Periode unter Umständen getriggert.
Ja.
Juud.
Okay.
Mir ist aufgefallen, dass sie im Anamnese-Gespräch super gut formuliert haben
und sehr gut gesprochen haben.
Danke schön.
Beim Artenarztgespräch haben sie ein bisschen mehr nach Worten gesucht,
aber das ist ja auch logisch.
Sie haben überhaupt keine Zeit gehabt,
irgendwas vorzubereiten oder zu formulieren.
Aber ich hatte eigentlich so wenig Verständnisprobleme
und ich denke mal, das ist doch für Premiere sehr gut gelaufen.
Ja, danke schön.
Ich hoffe, danke schön.
Und es ist ja tatsächlich noch lange Zeit bis zum, was?
Siebten November.
Na ja, okay.
Gut.
Okay.
Ja, dann haben wir es für heute schon geschafft.
Die waren schnell, die waren die Güte.
Ja, vielleicht.
Ja, gut.
Ja, dann sage ich eine schöne Grüße nach Mainz.
Noch mal, ne?
Und ja, wir sehen uns dann, was doch?
Ja, ja.